Olha essa aqui que não faz o menor
sentido. O país que mais usa protetor
solar no mundo é exatamente o que tem
mais câncer de pele. Pois é, na
Austrália acabou de estourar um
escândalo porque vários protetores
famosos não entregavam proteção
prometida no rótulo. Mesmo os protetores
que falharam nos testes ainda ofereciam
alguma proteção, porque estudos de 1990
já mostravam que até um FPS 16 reduzia
drasticamente o câncer de pele. Então
surge a questão mais importante. Será
que o problema não está só no protetor?
Austrália trata protetor solar como
medicamento, usa mais do que qualquer
outro país do mundo e continua sendo
campeã em câncer de pele. Isso me faz
pensar, se não estamos olhando só um
lado da moeda, e se a deficiência de
vitamina D causada justamente pelo
excesso de proteção solar não estiver
contribuindo para outros tipos de
câncer. Repensa aí, será que não estamos
de maneira errada exagerando na proteção
e esquecendo que o sol também é
essencial para nossa saúde?